he played back to the line M SM can't keep the
Zone but the coyotes will chip it out as it's
brought along by Logan coie over the line now
buad with a chance and Aon Krauss will play it
along comes out High double with a shot that's
ripped wide across I Apollo now to the line Mor
see shley to the front and a chance and I
of follow is robbed by goal tender Carell
Vin uh he was a waiver claimed by the Chicago
Blackhawks playing his first game for Chicago
in the windy city here tonight as this one will be
played to the front in schmalz as that's steered
Away by helot number two he sck for the first
time here tonight there's the high stick right
around the neck of Nick schaltz confront by
Pon look out here close to an interference
call Lowry wanted one but they're not going to
get it did they ever get away with one there
melli off the pipe at the other end so close
off the iron still no score here tonight late
first play a real simple game but effective
Ure desert Financial replay puckle be sent
behind the net in front and a goal a
turnover and domestica has made it one
nothing what a shot and the CES they get caught
everyone's looking behind the net the CES win
the draw too and John dersy has it gets his
pocket picked by Peretti and Peretti finds
nikov right out there in front Jersey loses that
battle Keller comes in to help and now eers for
cyle played in behind the net to the front and a
chance valard and it's covered by Vela to their
game they love to play below the top of the
circles heavy hard on the punck you see shley
there hopefully that's the case here tonight
gardian shley spun around now Schmidt and now
elers with it tried to drop it elers gets it
right back and he scores now carala lost his
stick and Nikolai elers there he is and
you talk about a guy back filling for a
guy like Kyle Conor continues to bring it 14
goals on the year look at the patience comes
up high and around and gets this puck right in
the Wheelhouse a Rolling Puck and he throws a
dart up top and I'm not sure how caraa lost
his stick I think it was the coyotes Matt
Dumba that knocked it out of Vela another
one no answer up for the Jets schaltz has
it again whips it back out High Keller across
schaltz penalty coming up here they score Nick
schaltz and it's a 2-1
game oh there you go that is a thing of beauty
is defensively you can't stop this that high
cycle they had the Jets all over the play
is running and then schaltz gets a feed from
Clayton Keller side door and he just throws
it at the net that goes off of The Stick of
the Jets defenseman and into the top corner of
the net over the globin Liam O'Brien comes in
to take the draw here against Adam Lowry
it'll be chipped out of there by Michael
carcone carcone to the for Kirkland oh he's
robbed that big body in the man they call
Big and boring just squares up flip back
out High to Melo across Mory and that was
blocked by McBain I think hu's enjoying this
he gets to take a seat on the bench first time
go gets the the rest he hasn't been on the
bench much as Mory across and Peretti and he
scores well the Jets on a delayed penalty
call get the extra attacker out and off to
the bench hellu goes the extra attacker and
look at Peretti a couple whacks at that one
he just wouldn't be denied great hand ey cord
n she ends up knocking this one right out of
midair and puck just drops right there on
the goal line to the left the hell Buck
left skate right there and H spit him behind
the net King Samberg and Hill Outlet maybe a
two-on-one short handed nestic off to the front
oh what a stop M huge save on Barrett was that
ever came up large how about nastic COV look
at this beauty of a pass to bar k will bring
it out nine to go in the period he's got
schs with [Applause] him Samberg took it
away but it comes in front Keller with a
shot at the hor and it's stopped by Conor
Helu Jersy sent one towards theet that goes
wide but I can promise you that the Jets are
going to give you nothing you got to go out
and earn it like right there elers with the
pocket now shle up the ice shley is in he
scores Mark shley and it's 4-1 up the ice
and stely a right-handed shot little
pump fake that's the old redeem verata
right there and when you do it right it
it's pretty much Unstoppable except this
time you're going to the the glove hand as
Dumba and again getting back to the Western
Conference race teams have caught the coyotes
I didn't even mention the Seattle Kraken go
through on the raer on and he scores Dylan
Gunther and it's a two goal game [Applause]
that's why they brought the kid up right
there dump that puck in Chase it down they
forced the turnover it was hellu one of the
best Puck playing goalies in the league gets
his pocket pick by Dylan Gunther and he stuffs
it little WP around dermit just a simple chip
and Chase look at the effort and now the Jets
are going to get it out and here they come up
the ice goes eers heers right to the flont
he stop by the M that was almost a two on0
I think El recognized sh was right beside
him back the other way there goes Vera to
the bench so they'll get the extra attacker
out and clear back to Center 218 to go on
regulation coyotes need to [Applause] Deuce
bu stat sends it around Keller on the pitch
back to the line valami they'll spin it
around now out High valami shoots over the
top and denied there out of the Zone
shley empty net that'll do it 52
Winnipeg and the Jets continue to roll and
that come the jets the other way safely but
again it it comes down to the group comes
down to the players that actually go on the
ice Lowry to the front try to send it across
for Mason Appleton under a minute remaining
in Period three Lowry to the front he scores
and it's 62 Winnipeg and they get a late one
and those are the ones that you really hate if
you're a goal well and for Carell Vela I mean
this certainly is not on him and that's
a little bit of a broken play not sure
if that went off the The Stick of mcbaine
but bowry just gets it and rips it over the
glove as jansson fby has it he shoots up
high and a stop there by Carell Vela and
that is going to do it so the win streak is at
or the excuse me the losing streak is at three